chopstick is an interactive cutting
board with built-in scale and measuring
devices and this bench concept allows
you to record a video to the cloud while
you sit on it which is linked to the
shadows cast by the bench that can later
be accessed with an augmented reality
app that reads the data from the
appearance of the shadows free sauce
Kevin here this is mind blow iBM is
working on a new computer prototype
fueled by electronic blood using the
human brain as a model the designing
them to be cooled and fueled by a liquid
just like the blood of a human brain
this new system pumps an electrolyte
blood through a computer carrying power
in and taking heat out and they hope by
2060 a one petaflop computer the size of
half a football field today will fit on
your desktop the neuro cam is a wearable
camera that automatically records what
interests you by analyzing your
brainwaves it works on a scale from 1 to
100 with a brainwave sensor that
connects to an iPhone if your interest
exceeds 60 the phone will automatically
start recording to produce a 5 second
animated gif or Jif the future of this
project is to create an emotional
interface that can use people's thoughts
and feelings for a wide range of
practical applications china's smog
problem could be helped by a new smog
devouring vacuum concept by using
underground copper coils the smog
particles are attracted and brought down
from the atmosphere to the ground
recently in a lab setting they created a
1 cubic meter smog free hole in a 555
meter room and the challenge is now to
create it on a larger scale for public
spaces
dung beetles gallop and it looks like
this
so yeah the aerial imaging plate
displays interactive images floating in
the air
developed by ahsoka net the image is
visible at a specific angle so only the
user is able to see it which would make
it safe to use at
ATMs and there are no fingerprints or
hygiene concern since the user is not
actually touching a screen like I is a
smart wheel that significantly upgrades
an ordinary bike it has a pedal assist
that's able to go up to 20 miles per
hour for 30 miles and is used in
conjunction with an app the smart light
attached to the handlebars has a pad
designed to hold your phone and also
charges it while you're riding the wheel
locks with the touch of a button and in
case your bike is stolen there's a GPS
tracking sent directly to your phone and
it can also suggest alternate routes
that may be faster or just more fun the
Poppy project from INRIA flowers is
trying to create everyday personalized
humanoid robots and even though it's not
quite ready to walk on its own it was
designed to better understand biped
locomotion and interactions between
humans and robots all of the parts for
the robot will be able to be 3d printed
or purchased from an electronics store
even though it may cost around eleven
thousand dollars to make your own cooler
canon star path from pro tech is a spray
applied elasto metric coating that
creates illuminated paths at night the
coating is applied in three layers it
only takes about half an hour to dry the
middle layer absorbs UV energy during
the day and emits this blue glow when it
gets dark the process can be applied to
many different surfaces including stone
paths driveways and even playgrounds the
Ivanpah solar electric generating system
will be the largest solar thermal power
tower system in the world located in the
california desert the amount of carbon
dioxide saved from going into the
atmosphere will be the equivalent of
taking 70,000 cars off the road and it
will generate electricity for 140,000
homes flirty is the first unmanned
aerial vehicle delivery technology zukul
comm is an online textbook resource
delivering text books via a drone in
sydney australia all you have to do is
order from the app on your smartphone
and the book will be shipped within
minutes but currently commercial flights
of UAVs are not legal in the United
States
finally tribo cycle created by Ben
Ridgeway is an absolutely mesmerizing
looping movie for large scale
projections and
installations
you
I'm going to leave you with a robotic
ape transitioning from a quadrupedal to
a bipedal posture and as always thanks
for watching